[Music]
[Applause]
our Arrington former NFL Penn State
linebacker he's got a podcast up on game
College Football Hall of Famer and uh
good to have him back on the program
Levar it's been a while how are you very
well sir how have you been I'm doing
okay if I said you got a pick which team
goes further Aaron Rodgers Tom Brady
I mean I'd have to go with any team in
the NFC right I mean if you think about
it the problems that Green Bay have are
very different than the problems that
that Tampa Bay has I I'm not certain
that Tampa Bay's problems aren't fixable
whereas you know with Green Bay it's
it's just
it just looks like the cover went from
being full or half full to to not being
um properly stocked Dan so I would most
likely say you know the NFC East is or
excuse me the NFC as a as a whole is
wide open but I I think that they have a
really really strong defense in Tampa
Bay they have great weapons on the
offensive side of the ball they just got
to put it together
as you're watching Green Bay and the
commanders you played for Washington do
you root for Washington
yes I do I do root for the team
um I root for the fan base I love the
city I love the fans I love the team I
just don't like the owner as I've made
that's uh that's been clear for for a
really long time in fact if you go back
into the annals DP I'm probably the
first one that was out there talking
about how crazy the dude is and how he
handles things with with his business
Affairs but that was during a time where
it wasn't very very pronounced and and I
got a lot of flack and a lot of blowback
on it as if I didn't like the fans or or
like the city but it was really the
owner that I dislike and still dislike
by the way is there one moment that
stands out
oh there's a few
I mean there's a few moments I mean they
they tried to paint a picture like I I
couldn't learn defenses
um they had Joe Gibbs on board with it
they had Greg Williams on board with it
and and you know there was there was a
an attempt an assassination attempt on
my character
um during the time that there was you
know contract issue which by the way I
would I did just to help the team you
know if if people remember uh what took
place but yeah I mean probably the
contract situation going the way that it
did is the most memorable because I
didn't have anything to do with it you
know I just I they asked me did I want
to redo my contract to help the team I
said I would I did it there was a
discrepancy in the contract and the rest
kind of uh went from there
yeah it I I'm just
I'm surprised the other owners don't say
you know what you're this guy's bad for
business
and but maybe they're worried that you
know it's going to be returned fire and
go oh you're going to talk about what
I'm doing do you know maybe I'm going to
tell people some of the things and
there's some powerful people that he
probably has dirt on
I mean you'd have to assume and and that
was released right I don't know how true
the statement was but I mean the sources
that released those reports that that
those were the things that were coming
from Dan Snyder's camp that you know he
he he's taking the whole ship down if if
they kick him off of it
um you'd have to assume that there's
some truth and validity to the things
that were being reported so I I don't
know where where that all stands but I
mean good for business is having an
owner of of a franchise that understands
how how the community works and and how
how Sports work and you know what at the
at the Bears minimum how how to talk and
treat you know treat the people that
work for you
well also the product you put on the
field at
you know you traded for wins and I I
didn't know I didn't think there was a
market for him Lamar it felt like if
they didn't get him he was going to be a
backup quarterback somewhere I'm uh you
know Taylor heinecke is fine until you
find a franchise quarterback if you do
but the product on the field has been
subpar we're talking to Levar Arrington
and uh you can hear up on game the I
Heart podcast plexigo Burrus uh TJ hush
manzada also two pros and a cup of joe
the show that precedes ours I listen to
it every morning coming in Fox Sports
Radio with uh Brady Quinn and Jonas Knox
on that uh program
um do you guys give Brady Quinn grief I
mean he's almost too good looking I
think is there he's perfect looking man
yeah you know he's got he's got a great
voice he's like a he's a young Dan
Patrick like you probably got a lot of
grief when you were younger yeah you
know you probably still get grief now
you know it's just those strikingly good
looks and the fine voice that you guys
is that we got to give you guys a hard
time I mean somebody's got to do it you
know and they hired me to be a part of
doing so but you hate quarterbacks right
quarterbacks always are the good I don't
guys they get the cheerleaders I don't
hate them
um but I I certainly never really like
them you know I just don't hate them but
in terms of you know the the cheerleader
Department I had game DP so I didn't
have to worry about the good looks my
game was good you know were you one of
the first guys to wear did he wear 11
I did I I create that's me 11 is me I am
I am Mr sticks the original but did were
there any you look faster when you wear
a number like that but I didn't know
given the the position that you played
yeah you know usually you're wearing a
number in the bigger number like 50 or
40 or you know but Derek Brooks wore
number ten so I ended up getting number
11 because I wanted to be Derrick Brooks
I I wanted number 10 when I went to
college but it was taken and I was kind
of like a little butt hurt about it but
they were like why not be the first you
instead of the next Derrick Brooks and I
was like oh that that makes sense so I
thought about a number that a linebacker
had never worn and made famous and I
came up with 11.
the Pro Football Hall of Fame like do
you make a case if people say should you
be in the Hall of Fame do you no I don't
do you fight for it no I don't I had a
good career
um I think you know when I went to when
I went to New York if I would have been
there my my contract was for seven years
had I been a part of those two Super
Bowls you can't put Eli Manning in the
the Hall of Fame if Levar Arrington
doesn't go into the Hall of Fame I would
have made a case if I'd have got two two
Super Bowls but
um three Pro bowls isn't I don't I don't
that's certainly not enough and then
College Football Hall of Fame I'm I'm
the best I'm a goat
I'm not even like I stack my career I
stack my highlight lights as as a
Defender I stack them up only person
that I'll say better than me in the
annals
um is probably Charles Woodson I'm
probably like the best college football
player that nobody really talks about
and I sound self-absorbed DP but you
know what this is the final frontier for
me this will be the last time that
football is is something where there's a
destination for me
um which is going into the college Hall
of Fame in December so I'm just kind of
living in that right now okay so the
best you're not talking about the best
defensive player in college football
you're talking about the bad defense no
I'm sad defense so Charles Woodson's the
best defensive player I think Charles
Woodson's the best player of all time
period
I think if you look at everything he's
done at every level oh so you're saying
the best football player if I take in
college and I take in the pros well with
Charles Whitson with me I just say
college defense defensive side of the
ball for me I don't think uh I'll I'll
take my you know I'll take my chances in
the debate so Charles Woodson the
greatest football player
I think Charles Whitson is the greatest
football player from top to bottom from
inception of playing till the time he
retired I think he's the greatest
football player ever uh let's look at
the AFC right now it feels like it's
just Buffalo and Kansas City and you
would be correct okay but I'm going to
make you a a defensive player facing you
can face Mahomes or uh or Allen in the
playoffs
if I had to choose I'd rather play
against Allen
because he's a more physical
grinder in the game like he'll bring the
game to you
and and so that would give me some type
of hope that we could actually turn it
into a game with my homes
it's it's he delivers the ball from so
many different angles and and the route
progressions that that they draw up the
schemes that they draw up uh with with
Coach Reed is it's kind of
it's just it's it's it's been unsolvable
he's in his own and no one is caught up
to him yet
yeah I guess as a Defender you want the
guy who's he's going to be right there
in front of you Josh Allen is going to
be right there in front of you right
there in front of you yeah absolutely
he's a big guy I think I think people
don't realize how big quarterbacks are
because we see what you guys do to them
but right you know being around Matt
Ryan's a legitimate six five maybe six
six Roethlisberger was a big guy yeah I
mean they're guys a lot of a lot of
those guys which makes you wonder why do
referees treat them like big old babies
right
okay solve it for me then
I mean it's contact football it's
contact Sports I say there's two ways of
approaching this either allow them to be
a part of the game
or don't
you know don't let like once you once
you
once you get to a certain perimeter you
know all this technology create an
invisible uh you know
parameter like like uh a dog you know
yeah sure like what they do with with
diamonds and stuff like that you know
you got the you know you got the
security you know the little red lines
around put the red lines around and make
that the sack so you don't have to touch
them
I don't know how you Micah Parsons
yesterday and you're going away yeah he
got called for roughing somebody got
called for roughing they they pulled
somebody down by one finger I'm just I
it's already Tough Enough it's tough
enough yeah it is if you touch a
quarterback anymore I mean the one with
Chris Jones was crazy like
that's crazy like you you you got to
them you're getting the ball you're
going down you're both going down you're
trying to secure the ball the ball is
still kind of in in the balance you're
trying to secure the ball you land on
him and they said you put too much
forced like too much of a percentage of
force on his body when he landed like
wait what do you mean too much of a
percentage of force on his but I don't
get that but there's all kinds of
different rules that are are governing
and protecting quarterbacks I get it
they sell tickets you know they're
they're the pretty guys as you mentioned
you know they do great interviews uh
they get the cheerleader but you know
what there are other guys out there that
that make the game go as well that that
would like to have a little bit of uh
time to enjoy with those quarterbacks on
Sundays what do you think is going to be
that Mark of if you get above this
number with sacks that that's going to
open the door for being a Hall of Famer
is it it's 100 sacks the number
foreign
if you get to 100 sack Club you are you
you have done something amazing
does that get you into the hall I don't
know
I don't I don't know but that is a
tremendous that is a tremendous
accomplishment to get to a hundred sack
Club
Aaron Donald just got over a hundred
that's a tackle
yeah uh you know he's from where I'm
from me we're Pittsburgh guys he's he's
from Penn Hills I'm from North Hills but
our families are are from the same area
I'm I'm super proud that he's from where
we're from I think he's one of he's he's
certainly the greatest defensive line uh
Defender
um I haven't seen a guy as dominant as
Aaron Donald
um since Reggie Reggie White like I I'm
a big fan of JJ Watt I'm a big fan of
Warren Sapp
um and the way that they played the game
there's a few more out there that that I
really like their games as defensive
linemen Defenders but Aaron Donald is
something of another and and I I enjoy
watching them play I you know he's
undersized but he is a brick s house and
he understands how to contort his body
and how to manipulate the hands and the
shoulders and and Leverage points of of
offensive blockers I just I just love
his game I love his motor love his game
who's the greatest so you think uh
Reggie White greatest defensive player
NFL history
greatest defensive player in NFL history
which is now being
being challenged by by Aaron Donald I
defensive player ever I would say
Lawrence Taylor
I'd say Lawrence Taylor still is the
most dominant defensive player we've
we've ever seen
um but when you're talking about the
versatility of being able to do the
things that Aaron Donald has done from
the different positions that he's done
it
um for the amount of time that he's done
it for
um it's it's up for a question but keep
in mind Lawrence Taylor did get MVP of
the league and I believe he's the only
Defender to ever get that accomplishment
when you get that good anybody gets that
MVP of the league award DP then now you
can start to have the conversation of
they may be better or greater than LT
but until then that man still stands on
on a mountain alone
good to talk to you congratulations
College Football Hall of Fame so much
appreciate it uh that's uh
LaVar Arrington joining us the up on
game I heart podcast with TJ hushman
Zada and uh plexico Burris also two pros
and a cup of joe